this parking lot in California is piling
up with empty Boeing and Airbus aircraft
planes that until recently were busy
flying people to places and then
suddenly people stopped flying daily
traffic is down some 80 percent from its
peak in 2019 airlines are fighting for
survival as Airport activity has fallen
to near zero meanwhile industry giants
Boeing and Airbus have seen order
cancellations and furloughed or laid off
staff I don't believe the industry has
ever seen anything like this and because
of that there is no one you can turn to
we literally are all learning as we go
Boeing already weakened by the 737 max
crisis saw its stock drop more than 70
percent in February and March while air
buses fell about 65 percent in the same
period the plane makers employ hundreds
of thousands of people in several
countries and their major economic
players often at the center of global
politics both those companies nobody has
an interest in retaining government
equity in their company we can recover
from these crisis
so as the corona virus pandemic shakes
up the industry we wanted to know what
will it take for Boeing and Airbus to
survive this unprecedented crisis and
what does it mean for the future of
aviation before coronavirus Boeing was
already struggling to get regulator
approval to return its 737 max to the
skies as the jet was grounded after two
deadly accidents linked to a faulty
flight control system in another blow
Boeing recently dropped its 4.2 billion
dollar bid to team up with Brazilian jet
maker Embraer which was supposed to
transform the aviation industry and
Airbus had already overtaken Boeing as
the world's top plane maker in terms of
deliveries we think our capacity to to
compete and be strong on the long term
is intact if not improved
I wanted to get a better idea of how
well-positioned the plane makers are to
withstand this crisis so I called
Addison Sean Lind a partner at air
insight it appears as we sit here right
now there's an advantage to Airbus given
its particular tools available to
Airlines Boeing is at a disadvantage now
because of the Mac's grounding and the
incompletion of the Boeing Brasil
project now the corona virus pandemic
has forced the companies to draft
survival plans we will be suspending all
travel from Europe to the United States
for the next 30 days air passenger
volumes felt more than 90% sending
Airlines into crisis in February major
airlines like Delta and United started
to cut their losses by canceling some
flights only weeks later the collapse
and air travel had already trickled down
to Boeing and Airbus with many orders
being postponed or canceled in the first
three months of 2020 Boeing saw
customers cancel 196 of its aircraft
orders Airbus had 66 cancellations and
said almost all of its customers have
approached it to discuss deferring or
canceling orders
you know we're accustomed to bad years
like 9/11 or the SARS year Gulf War one
but at the end of the day this is just
an unprecedented freezing up of the the
end user market even in this crisis both
Boeing and Airbus have a key customer
they can count on governments there's
some of the world's biggest defense
contractors with the US Navy even
ordering new planes from Boeing amid the
pandemic the ultimate safe haven right
now is defense particularly US defense
programs
through their history boeing and airbus
have become ingrained in defense
industrial development and geopolitics
boeing has worked with the US government
to build military planes since World War
one and Airbus is very inception is
deeply rooted in European politics as it
was formed as an example of how European
countries and companies are stronger
when they come together
Airbus doesn't have a hundred years of
history but if you look at what Airbus
consists of all those European aerospace
companies that came together that were
also very old brought with them
amazing amount of knowledge Boeing and
Airbus both spend millions of dollars on
lobbying every year they've criticized
each other for getting unfair government
subsidies and they're both massive
employers with roughly one hundred and
sixty one thousand and one hundred and
thirty four thousand employees
respectively so a major hit to one of
their bottom lines means a potential hit
to a lot of American and European jobs
when the US government was crafting its
two trillion dollar coronavirus stimulus
package a big part of the bailout was
focused on the aviation industry the
bill included 17 billion dollars for
companies deemed essential to national
security which could potentially include
Boeing here's the thing as of early May
some airlines had applied for government
aid but Boeing hadn't and the idea of
Boeing getting bailed out by taxpayer
money is sensitive you can imagine that
those companies the management is going
to fight tooth and nail to prevent the
government saying here's 60 billion
dollars by the way here's the warrants
and years the stuff that we're taking
that we own you
any loans offered by the government
would likely come with strings attached
like limiting stock buybacks layoffs and
giving the US government a stake in the
company something Boeing CEO suggested
he wouldn't be open to I don't have a
need for an equity stake if they force
it we just totally just look at all the
other options and we've got plenty of so
what are the options for Boeing and
Airbus to keep the cash flowing
in May Boeing raised 25 billion dollars
from private investors and said it
didn't expect to need any more funds
including government aid but Boeing has
already suffered a number of new
setbacks
it's now facing civil and criminal
scrutiny over the 737 max crisis it
suspended its dividend is offering staff
buyout packages and plans to cut its
workforce by 10 percent this year
abbis and the board aerospace sector
will emerge from this difficult period
aventurine Airbus also needs to cut
spending but after the pandemic analysts
expect the market for smaller planes to
grow because domestic travel is expected
to bounce back first and Airbus can
offer its direct competitor to the 737
max its best-selling a320 family that
includes the a320 one lr a single aisle
plane that's capable of transatlantic
routes Boeing really doesn't have a
competitor to that yet and both
companies will likely face a big supply
chain issue Boeing and Airbus rely on a
massive network of smaller companies
that are struggling to survive it's a
million parts that you see flying in
close formation that is actually an
airplane all those parts come from all
kinds of places around the globe some of
these places that the companies that
make these small parts are literally
family-owned they're tiny they don't
have the resources if if this system is
shaken up like this how do you protect
them analysts say it could potentially
take several years before the aviation
industry recovers but whenever people
will need new planes they'll likely come
from Boeing or Airbus not that there are
many alternatives the duopoly makes up
about 99% of all large commercial plane
orders with China's state-run plane
maker believed to be 10 to 20 years out
from becoming a real competitor
will the companies be different at the
end of this pandemic probably the longer
it goes the more that there will be some
kind of structural change but neither of
those companies based where they are are
dispensable so I think that whatever
happens we come through this and there
may be they may be different but they
will remain the two top dogs in that
industry